i can't wait it'll be so cool to you
know see yourself pod racing and using
the force and
i can't wait it's insanity you know i
grew up on the stuff what is your agenda
what kind of commitment to have you made
uh well right now i'm you know trying to
get in shape and
buff up a little bit uh i'm gonna start
taking bo classes which is a stick
fighting course
uh and then i leave for australia the
end of the beginning of june i'm very
lucky and i couldn't be happier right
now
in the shadow of darth vader the
canadian native told me he got the word
last wednesday and broke the news to his
mom over the phone with theatrical
flourish it was funny my roommate
has a star wars
soundtrack on record
so we started blaring it in the
background
and my mom heard it in the background
she started flipping out you call this a
diplomatic solution no i call it
aggressive negotiations
natalie was was uh really amazing to
work with she's you know really
committed actress and we were kind of
partners in crime at times just got
along really well when you were cast the
clincher was
working with natalie do you do actual
scenes from the script to test your
chemistry together it was a modified uh
version of one of the scenes in the
scenes in the film it's uh the one where
where i'm
talking to her about how you know a jedi
is actually allowed to love and how it's
almost encouraged you're exactly the way
i remember you and my dreams
the love story with natalie is obviously
you know a pivotal theme you know for
for both you know the star wars saga and
you know especially for my character
because it's it's something that uh you
know
leads anakin towards towards the dark
side almost it's it's something that
he's you know forbidden to to really
experience and something that he also
feels so passionately about that uh it
you know creates this huge conflict in
him and sort of
uncertainty that that you know forces
him to follow his his own instincts more
so than you know the guidance of obi-wan
and the ways of the jedi
and you know ultimately the beginning of
his own downfall
it's all obi-wan's full
he's jealous
he's holding me back
do you have a favorite moment in the
film or favorite scene to be honest it
was it was the long shot of of me uh
just standing there talking to uh you
know one of the jawa people
on the tatooine planet uh just because
that was where i kind of
most felt like like you know there i was
in a star wars film it was it was you
know most reminiscent of the previous
trilogy i felt
we trained for about five hours every
day
and
it was you know extensive work but you
know something that i thoroughly enjoyed
you know knowing that eventually what i
was holding was gonna you know be lit up
and you know john williams music was it
was gonna be you know superimposed on
top of that
i have failed you anakin
i have failed you i don't really know
too much what's going to happen in the
next one i think i need to wipe out the
entire jedi race you know i think at
some point i get to
wear the dark helm and you know really
get to wear a full darth vader garb
[Music]